today on sneak this i can't believe we
got him
floyd the mailman
[Music]
gentlemen have you seen anybody wear the
post office air force ones what there's
such a thing yeah can we get you going
right here can we throw them up you
might not be aware of this but in the
sneaker world you're basically santa
claus with us oh yeah man i thought i'd
been santa claus for a long time now to
be honest with you the guy's coming to
your door man leave me a plate of
cookies you know what kind of shoes do
you wear as a mailman uh the new balance
they have a work series like 626.
when you see a house are there any signs
that a sneaker head lives there sure
you're gonna see the same those boxes
constantly coming like that coming up i
mean i pretty much can tell what's
coming through and what's coming into
the mail some of those boxes with the
black bags but you know there's a
magazine in there there's only one
magazine they deliver in a black bag
whenever you're shipping a pair of
sneakers they always ask you how much do
you want to insure these for so that's
why we're playing the game how much
would you insure these sneakers for i i
wouldn't pay more than 120 for those how
much of these
out are you serious yeah that's not the
same shoe it's definitely different i
bet you're insuring these two and a
quarter two and a quarter 225
dollars these are going for like eight
thousand dollars
okay uh
for 450 dollars times three 22.50 like
12k 375. 20 000. the new balance is one
of my favorite brands they're always
reasonably priced for the working man
i'd say
2.95 pretty reasonable this is the 450.
finally if you give one piece of advice
for the sneakerheads out there in the
world
what would you tell them
get to know your mailman you get your
mailman kids